you're out for a routine Space Walk
suddenly your helmet comes loose
but instead of suffocating you breathe
in fresh Cosmic air
how far reaching would this space
atmosphere be
why would space suddenly become so loud
and could this lead to the destruction
of the whole solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if outer space was breathable
the atmosphere you breathe here on Earth
consists of 78 nitrogen 21 oxygen and
Trace Amounts of other gases it's that
molecular oxygen that is essential for
life
molecular oxygen is rare beyond the 10
000 kilometers that the atmosphere
extends above the Earth's surface
in space oxygen atoms bind with space
dust
they react with hydrogen atoms and
create water ice instead of molecular
oxygen
but what if we could find breathable air
all the way to the edges of the
heliosphere
that's the boundary where the Sun's
gravity is no longer as strong as that
of other stars
would an expansive atmosphere mean you
could travel anywhere in space and
breathe like you do here on Earth
wait you're about to explore this
breathable universe and that's what
you're wearing come on let's step up
your style and check in with the sponsor
of today's video true classic true
classic is the premium brand for
essential teas activewear and almost
everything else you want or need well
check it out for yourself thanks to
their True Fit custom sizing system
their clothes hug you in all the right
places regardless of your size or shape
and their website is amazing you'll find
dozens of color combinations here and
you can pick pre-assembled outfits to
expand your wardrobe and if you need
even more incentive well right now you
can get 25 off your entire true classic
order when you use the promo code what
if a checkout that's promo code what if
at
trueclassictees.com what if hey order
now because unlike my shirt this deal
won't last
besides that surprising breath of fresh
air there would be some other big
changes you'd hear of
you'd now be able to listen to the sun
and the other planets
in the vacuum of space sound can't
travel
that's because there are too few
molecules between the planets and the
stars to carry the vibrating sound waves
but in this new space atmosphere those
sound waves could travel great distances
so you'd be able to hear everything loud
and clear
the sun is constantly vibrating at
different frequencies it would be so
loud that it would seem deafening even
considering the great distance between
our star and the Earth's surface it
would still reach your ears at a volume
of
125 decibels
imagine going about your daily routine
to a soundtrack similar to church bells
only it would be as loud as thousands of
police sirens
this would be annoying but it wouldn't
be your biggest problem
in the vacuum of space there's no
friction
that means all the planets and moons
orbit the sun without losing speed
or at least losing it very very slowly
but now with outer space filled with air
all the planets would be slamming into
air particles at very high speeds
the Earth would experience the same fate
as the asteroids that enter our planet's
atmosphere
the friction causes them to heat up and
burn
so with the Earth currently orbiting the
Sun at a velocity of 30 kilometers per
second all that friction would leave us
with nothing more than scorched surfaces
and this would be far from the end of
the chaos
eventually the moon would slow to a
complete stop
yeah then Earth's gravity would pull the
Moon closer and that would result in a
devastating Collision
if you survived through the scorched
Earth this crash would be the end for
the whole planet
it would tear the Earth apart
the rest of the solar system wouldn't
fare much better with so much air in it
our solar system could turn into a black
hole
this is because all this air would have
mass
and with the radius of the heliosphere
spanning 90 astronomical units
that's a lot of mass
yeah about 5 billion times more than the
sun itself
so if the sun's gravitational pull made
all this Mass compressed toward it the
solar system would become increasingly
dense
if all that air compressed into a space
about 80 percent of the Earth's diameter
dude witnessed the creation of a black
hole
I I mean if you were still alive at that
point
that's unlikely
that black hole would be about 1200
times more massive than the supermassive
black hole in the middle of the Milky
Way
okay at this point you and I would be
long gone and
it might be for the best because it
looks like these two gravitational
monsters are about to collide
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]